doch wir den präsentiert forum baggers
[Musik]
was ist das für sie trotz doping hatten
hängen als kinderlose frau war natürlich
wieso nicht kompensiert die
kinderlosigkeit und da seien ideal dafür
katzen sind die beliebtesten haustiere
sie werden verwöhnt und manchmal auch
vernachlässigt es ist mir über den kopf
gewachsen einfach ja und ich konnte aber
nicht also nicht sagen ich verzichte auf
die katzen
weshalb sind katzen so beliebt welchen
aufwand betreiben menschen für ihre
kuscheltiere und weshalb wird als haupt
ihr selber vom jäger zum gejagten
mit diesen fragen brechen wir auf zu
einer reise durchs katzen land schweiz
[Musik]
dieses haus hat 15 zimmer zwölf davon
sind ausschließlich für edel katzen
reserviert eine hudelist hobbyzüchter
und stolzer besitzer von 22 ägyptischen
mal mit diesem rasse tieren spielt er
täglich mehrere stunden
natürlich lief nicht so niedermachen
so werde traffic athletisch und dieser
zeigt damit bildet von samtpfoten war
der 63-jährige immer schon fasziniert
grüne rudel war früher schulleiter und
lehrer vor 17 jahren wurde er wegen
einer seltenen schlafkrankheit
frühpensioniert und iv bezüger die
beschäftigung mit seinen tieren würde im
leben zu end geben
ich werde bucht
ich spüre dass sie brauchte erst spät
was sie erwartet und verbote ist nicht
wichtig was ich mochte bis waschen
bürsten oder die studenten
sie stammt aus kuba mit und gab mir sehr
viel zurück zu erwarten sie zeigen dass
sie mit leeren hand da sind wir brauchen
dass sie freie hand und was will man ihm
seine frau silvia ist noch berufstätig
die heilpädagogin teilt sich das hobby
ihres mannes
es beansprucht ihre ganze freizeit
zusammen gegangen sind noch zwei wochen
ist sie ja nicht weg und bin ich kotze
vermisst haben
ferien gemacht wo man kann sein können
bieten ein test durch dummys autos
herzelinde runden tisch der partner oder
kurze ja ich denke schon
oder war's nicht aber das gilt das ist
einmal das von einem fremden und ja ja
ja so in fast jedem zimmer seines hauses
steht ein bett auf grund seiner
schlafkrankheit narkolepsie muss ich
renne rudel mehrmals täglich hinlegen so
einfach und vor allem die eintönigen
alte ist das schlimm wenn ich irgendwie
aktiv beim stress wie den unterdrückt
das ist so wenn ich in der business
klasse
das ist schwer also noch zwei minuten
brauchte einfach wie will oder nicht
länger als 90 minuten könne er nie am
stück schlafen auch nachts nicht
seit 17 jahren arbeitet er nicht mehr
zum glück habe er ein hobby sagt seine
frau ich finds gut denn so hätte
tagesstruktur also erste hauzenberger
ein munteres putze und so sah sie dass
man dass man sagt also nie zu wichtig
oder warum ist oder wenn es um ihr
dasein also vor dem h finde ich sehr gut
[Musik]
ein elektrozaun 400 meter lang ein
hochsicherheitstrakt für stubentiger
20000 franken hat der zaun gekostet
dafür streunen die tiere nicht im
quartier herum
so schützt manuela gutermann ihre sieben
schnur ließ sowie eine wechselnde anzahl
pflege katzen
monatlich gibt sie rund 500 franken für
futter aus hochwertig müsse es sein
sagte informatikern für ihre tiere sei
nur das beste gut genug auf das ihn
wirklich mich aber sie bedeutet muss
sehr sehr viel und du daraus dass sie
wieder honickel arbeit während ihrem
schöpfer bin muss ich auch schon sagt er
man freut sich drauf warum hobby kairo
da wird mir begrüßen und das ist noch
der bisher sehr schön so dass ich meine
terrasse die honey explizit vernetzt aus
offenburg gibt muss man sagen
740 da wirklich absolute hammer fusion
gestellt spiels auch hans waren die
jüngeren sind und nur wand spielen es
gibt kein ruhm was nicht trotz bahn hat
dort regen den ton an
dort reden welche päckli hat was ein
schlafzimmer sind willkommen bin absolut
auf jeden fall nicht auch sehr schön mit
ihm schlafen und am morgen hat sie
morgen wieder zu woche jeweils nicht
scheitere an bord war im bett als holz
noch eigentlich wäre das natürlich schon
viel schulden noch aus aber es sehr
schön aber man muss die richtigen finden
damit sie überhaupt akzeptiert brewster
neben vollkriegen bussen unsereiner
betreuung sie haben heute privat für
kurzeinsätze
die 53-jährige ist gründerin des vereins
katzenfreunde schweiz
sie nimmt verwilderte oder ausgesetzte
vierbeiner bei sich auf um sie zu
pflegen
später sucht sie für die fellnasen ein
neues zuhause
diesen wurf junger büsis hat sie von
einem bauern bekommen auf dessen hof
leben schon zahlreiche andere katzen
guter mann sagt dass landwirte oftmals
frisch geborenen tiere töten würden um
deren bestand zu verkleinern
außerdem hat das heißt man zur häme und
jetzt im große ganze derzeit immer noch
wachse wenn sie sehen die zum die sechs
bis sieben euro woche laut und
schlussendlich künstlers neueste heime
in jedem vierten schweizer haushalt lebt
eine katze allein schon von ihrer anzahl
her sind sie die beliebtesten haustiere
mit den rund 1,7 millionen katzen
hierzulande lässt sich gutes geld
verdienen
laut branchenführer qualität geben die
schweizer jährlich 420 millionen franken
aus für schneuwly
das wäre möbel abteilung für kratzer
daher es sophie kratzer liegen natürlich
gerne auf dem sofa weiter geht's mit den
verschiedenen kratzbaum meter und
spezielle kratzbaum aus olivenholz da
immer zum beispiel gefühlt die kurz
liegen mit 10 cent hinter herzlich form
es gibt da zum beispiel auch spezielle
bausteine multivitamin tauschte auch
unbegrenzt im spiel spaß für haus gasse
für beschäftigung da wird zwar
eigentlich möglich nicht langweilig 3
markeng
das schon auch das rätsel auf da immer
verschiedene bach berührte auf
demokratische art zum beispiel
harmonisierend wir können natürlich ein
trend mit zum beispiel ein hahn gefüllt
mit baldrian
an der zürcher goldküste gibt es ein
luxushotel für katzen die gebürtige
brasilianerin jeanette rührt bietet
ferienplätze für 100 tiere
fast immer sei das hotel ausgebucht bis
zu 140 franken kann eine übernachtung
kosten
doch nicht alles bieten sind so teuer
dafür ein bei der bis 3 kostet 111 also
pro nacht immer pro nacht alles
inclusive gut gebucht und sehr gut
gebucht ist
ivan basso it es ist direkt am fenster
um die habe diese wunderschöne aussicht
in die weite
einen schönen ausblick haben die
fellnasen auch auf einen flachbildschirm
da wird dann kurzen affären sido ja auch
das office und beispiele sie war gerade
vorher sein
jederzeit können besitzer mit ihren
lieblingen via skype kontakt aufnehmen
nachdem sie machen sie gar kein star
kann der geht sehr gut zwei angestellte
helfen bei der betreuung der kleinen
gäste offensichtlich ist dass katzen
fünf-sterne-hotel eine wahre goldgrube
[Musik]
multi-millionärin sei sie geworden ohne
je arbeiten zu müssen denn die
beschäftigung mit katzen sei nichts
anderes als spaß betont jeanette arthur
[Musik]
fast jedes wochenende finden irgendwo
landauf landab misswahlen für katzen
statt
[Musik]
das ist auch eine rudels wählt er ist so
etwas wie der heimliche star der szene
seine tiere werden regelmäßig an
schönheitswettbewerben prämiert
[Musik]
wegen seiner schlafkrankheit muss er an
solchen anlässen immer medikamente
einnehmen damit er nicht einschläft
so hat er keinen stress den stress haben
sondern umstellung naja das flugzeug
sicher der tester weiter freude zu leben
und schöne hier liegt zeigen und ja es
tut mir gut wenn man das kurz vor der
hütten und wandten sie sich für katzen
aus als er ist nein ich will auch was
das ergebnis betrifft also nimmt für die
eu da muss ich ganz klar sagen endlich
wenig verstanden ist wenn man eigentlich
so busek sieht ja wohl bestelltes vor
angst und sich versteckt unter einer
möglichen
[Musik]
der anlass scheint seinen gewohnten
verlauf zu nehmen
doch dann passiert es eine von models
katzen nimmt reißaus
die konkurrenz hilft mir das tier
einzufangen
das ist ehrensache ein mann wird dabei
gebissen
[Musik]
hilfe erhält er von manuela guter mann
sie ist oft an solchen ausstellungen
anzutreffen waren jetzt wirklich richtig
zur pci standard detail lasse das spitz
dass gott an kondition sind wieder auf
das kultur und das festungen ob es geht
der fluchtversuch des kleinen raubtiere
es dauerte nur wenige minuten
wir sehen etwas ist einen angriff von
denen heute wahrscheinlich erheblich
böses mögen noch so putzig sein
sie bleiben jäger katzen töten
hierzulande jährlich fast zwei millionen
vögel und 600.000 reptilien schätzt pro
natura die naturschützer sind alarmiert
vor allem in dicht besiedelten gebieten
reißen katzen viele tiere jedes zehnte
davon gehört zu einer bedrohten art der
oper sind wohnquartiere da ist gerade
schutzgebiet mitteilte
mit der schmidt libelle iba stufen und
im juli hexe und die sind opfer von der
katze vor der viele hartz iv hausen
wohngebieten räume
als fdp grossrat im aargauer
kantonsparlament forderte jene 2015 den
abschuss von herrenlosen katzen seine
interpellation wurde zwar abgelehnt aber
jene geriet ins kreuzfeuer von
katzenfreunden ja doch jetzt nachdem die
ganz ganz rabiat die reaktionen ganz
wenig aufgeregt sie hat mein kasimir ist
ein angstraum ihres pc aber kann er ja
im allgemeinen gute jäger keine elitäre
im wald müssen auf einem verwilderten
die hart und um die ihr gott will die
oder gott vor allem weil die sind nicht
nur für natur als problem sondern sie
lieder aus er starb als er sie
unterstütze nach wie vor jeder sagen
will die haut zudem schlugen sie im
speziellen fall wo sie es verwildert der
hand der schnittkurs damit dass sie das
versuchen
und ich hoffe das ist viel der größte
stress aus superschuss tester auch er
kadermitglied bei pro natura verlangt
unter anderem eine leinenpflicht für
katzen herumstreunende schnurlos hätten
nichts im fein verloren und wenn doch
nur im umzäunten garten weil das so ist
die ihr dorf im noch bringt orten ihnen
einfach dort unter wachsen dann in den
garten in schießen erklärt stroms
liefert sich saal bereit fördern oder
viele verstarben im straßenverkehr
ich finde dass die art vorhang wie
manche betriebe mit entsprechendem was
unser die bringen umgekehrt er sei nicht
grundsätzlich ein katzen feind sagt
johannes jenny zum beweis will ihren
milli zeigen seine familienkasse dort
spüre das sehen wir da hatte krämpfe
es ist eigentlich bin ich eher ein
vorteil hier blind
also sie kommt jedermann und sie zu mir
du
millys revier ist beschränkt auf jenes
garten der naturschützer legt hier
gerade ein biotop an ideen ist ein
hüpfen können sie sich den fachlichen
jetzt hat sie es
[Musik]
da sehe ich doch gerade das was sie
eigentlich bekannt verdoppelt ja das ist
das ist problematisch ich habe also eine
s-bahn zur band mit dem macht man so
eine krause russ und dich du jetzt die
pailletten rufname und den nach haare
nur kamera auf das bessere
ob es den text nicht verschreckt werden
sodass sie flüchten bevor sie fressen
sie dann überhaupt 20 finde man halte
block aus liebe ich auch gern und ich
hatte jetzt will ich nicht selber keine
kinder und mini frau die ihr buch
ein bauernhof oberhalb von grafenort im
kanton nidwalden willi und vreni ambauen
haben auf ihrem hof zu viele katzen
deshalb kontaktierte das ehepaar
tierschützer diese wollen heute die
vierbeiner einfangen und kastrieren
lassen
problem sind aber für jungen das ist der
rcz das ist ganz klar zu da ist auch die
treibende kraft der aktion ist die
tierschutzorganisation will die
vermehrung der fast 1,7 millionen katzen
in der schweiz eindämmen
es hat einfach unglaublich viele
herrenlose oder vernachlässigt die
konten in der schweiz mehr redet auf 100
du sie gerne vor einzelfall und jeder
wohl absichtlich nachwuchs setzt tut das
natürlich verstärken will um das hat
wenig platz für die bücher und
einschätzungen vor 100 pro jahr aus wo
aktiv dort werdet wissen jemand mut und
zum das verhindere gibt es nur eins ein
fachbegriff kastrieren kastrieren
kastrieren
[Musik]
ja
ab zum nächsten bauernhof 80 katzen
werden an diesem tag eingefangen
[Musik]
an der katzenausstellung stehen die
prämierungen an könne rudel ist voller
selbstvertrauen
oft schon hat er mit seinen ägyptischen
maul die konkurrenz ausgestochen der
jury präsentiert er nun ein büsi mit dem
noblen namen bahrami von skarabäus
dass sie kauft eine expertin
sie ist fälle ist im qualitäts kontraste
auch das thema das ist toll
dann wird die schönste gekürt und auch
hier haben wir viele junge nennt man den
nummer 143 beim namen lautet dieser
bahrami von skarabäus
[Musik]
die schöne wurde übrigens im vergangenen
jahr mit dem titel national gewinnerin
ausgezeichnet für mich eigentlich
erlebten mauritz dass ich lieber nicht
so viele haben und damit die anderen
westen machen
gleich nebenan gibt es für katzenfreunde
eine auslage an schmuck 500 da kann ich
dann schon ein bisschen sie sich nach
dem tod hinaus nur dem hier vom
festhalten
ich weiß es ist aber es ist vor dem ziel
hat
für julie nancy bill gates ist das
herstellen von schmuck nur eine
freizeitbeschäftigung
die 55 jährige ist selbständige
vermögensverwalterin ihre betuchte
kundschaft wählt sie gezielt aus zu
menschen hat die geschäftsfrau ein
gespaltenes verhältnis
ich bin motiviert im business enttäuscht
und betrogen boote und das machen mache
mir nicht und ich kann auch sieht er
sage seit ich die menschen kennen liebe
ich die tiere
[Musik]
das anwesen von judy nancy bell dales um
fast 12.000 quadratmetern
dazu gehören mehrere beiden ställe und
ein offener reitplatz bei schlechtem
wetter kann sie in ihrer eigenen
überdachten halle dem hobby nachgehen
[Musik]
zahlreiche tiere sind auf dem grundstück
daheim
[Musik]
eine angestellte entlastet die
besitzerin
das ist eine familiäre bringen da man
jetzt sagen das ist von ruß eine familie
bringen das studio das ist ein hammer
dauert sie zwei lausbuben die american
miniature horses sony und mini mit der
kammerspiele zirkuskunst eclipse bringen
einfach spaß da oben sind raketen sind
auf dem paddock sie das ist ein
15-jähriger lusitano herrscht das
ganztägige programm so will der hat das
haben wir als angestellte für das handy
oder alex und der roller sichergestellt
der letzte arbeitstag
aber auch nach der muss sagt das ist so
in rom kehrte der moment schaffte jetzt
tut er das umgekehrte fall sie dass er
jetzt für mich schafft als kind durfte
die gebürtige kanadierin keine eigenen
tiere haben
heute gehören ihr nebst sieben pferden
auch noch fünf hunde die vierbeiner sind
für sie die kinder das gilt ganz
speziell für ihre fünf katzen als
kinderlose frau natürlich bisher nicht
kompensiert die kinderlosigkeit und da
sind seien ideal dafür oder wie sie sind
und was sie machen sie haben sieben also
machte sie die babys sei empfinde es ist
ein einsatz am anfang für richtig mein
unglückliches sie aber jetzt mit der
zelter dass man wird muss man sagen hat
mir weniger sorgen wenn mit ihr hat sich
ja was würdet ihr stroh hier oder dort
nach das wort der sich in kühlen aber
ich würde ich es hatte sich ja warum
batterien stinkt beschützerinstinkt ich
kann es nicht sagen aber das ist dass
ich spiele meistens in jesus sagte
einmal ich muss das akzeptieren kann ich
aus einigen orientieren oder will wenn
da sind mit reis und das nicht trotz
akzeptieren denn deutsche partner
votieren oder dann moment das anders
die edle tiere bewohnen den oberen stock
des hauses gesehen
es sind rasser haupt und aus können sie
natürlich ne dose oder offen landes
würde es natürlich nicht lange überleben
oder gestohlen allenfalls und das wird
millionen tiere also die eigene wohnung
wir hatten eigentlich wann ich glaube ja
die haben 123 zimmer mit kochen und auch
jene hand sie sei es ist natürlich
zwischen investment teile wobei die
gäste zu zeigen dass krieg und dahin
haben wir noch mal so ein spielzimmer wo
wir noch hart bäume die in hand wir
haben da hin noch ausbauen und das da
ist fernseh ecke dass ich sie mir zauber
und fernseher mit gemüse und den
kommission ist und sie zitate und merle
getan unzählige du sollst ruf und gemüse
das und ich glaube sie genieße die zeit
da wo mir dein name für sie dass sie mit
äußeren zusammen sie wenn wir doch halte
kompromiss haben wir machen mit günter
sie trafen sich sind aber darin luxo
sagst dann nur honig gewürze oder ja
hätte ich hin wert jedoch hin und ich
hasse ihn hält also sind sie da katzen
werden oft verwöhnt aber manchmal auch
vernachlässigt
zu hause bei der ehemaligen katzen
züchterin helga k
jahrelang lebte sie mit bis zu 60 tieren
zusammen
mehrmals schon schritt das veterinäramt
ein
die meisten ihrer katzen wurden
beschlagnahmt zweimal wurde sie wegen
tierquälerei zu hohen bussen verurteilt
milderung das mendener oder wegnimmt
das darf man nicht ich habe ein recht
tiere zu halten jeder hat und dass es
mir nicht gefallen aber sie sind ja
schon zweimal verurteilt wurden weil sie
quasi prozent richtig konnte das tier
quelle reden
ich kann nur lachen tierquälerei
fotografiert und sie weiter dann können
sie selbst beurteilen ob ich die tiere
quer oder nicht auf gut deutsch gesagt
das sind idioten und das wiederhole ich
sind idee die gehege entsprachen nicht
dem tierschutzgesetz
sie waren für die vielen katzen zu klein
und zu dunkel
helga k sieht das anders
auch ein ganz großes haus noch
man riecht noch immer die kriegen sie
nie mehr weg ein paar ihrer vierbeiner
waren unterernährt oder von parasiten
befallen
die beschlagnahmten katzen wurden ins
tierheim gebracht
die alleinstehende und verwitwete
rentnerin durfte von ihren 60 tieren
deren 15 behalten
für diese gibt es nun genügend platz die
vierbeiner breiten sich im ganzen haus
aus man sieht und riecht die stubentiger
überall zugeklebt weil die katzen da
hier noch einige kratzer
so treffen sie sich und das wird immer
schlimmer
oder die katze die überall stehen und da
stört sie nicht dass couchepin eine
vertonung zerstört und dollar sei ich
sage jetzt seien aber zum teil bietet
das möchte er sehr stark noch wenn man
kleine kinder hat und tier ist man
nämlich wenn man neuer möbel rein tut
die kinder müssen großgezogen werden die
die ersten lernen da war es auch hier
was auch katze tun genau das selbe die
kratzen noch die die tiere die kinder
tun genau das selbe ist ein wahnsinn
neue möbel anzuschaffen entweder meine
ich super schön eingerichtet oder man
hat ihren beides zusammen geht nicht
die tiere riechen an sich sie riechen
setzten sich irgendwo hin dass ich es
nicht mehr nein als jetzt fühlt sie ihr
gelübde tier überfordert mit dem ruder
und so wilde katze überhaupt nicht in
keiner weise ich habe keine hilfe von
keinem auch nur nötig wenn mal etwas
technisches ist dann kommt der sohn aber
sonst werde ich mit allem allein fertig
ich habe ein auto
ich hab's internet ich hab's fernsehen
ich hab die tiere beschwert mit allem
allein fertig gesprochen niemand auch
nicht weiter autofahrten ich brauche
niemand
verstöße gegen das tierschutzgesetz
kommen häufig vor
allein beim veterinärdienst bären gehen
jährlich über 350 meldungen ein
die meisten davon betreffen überforderte
katzenhalter das ist der hauptgrund für
die zwei und nummer bereits aber
generell das blüte beförderten sie unter
schwierigkeit des ortes gibt es gar
nicht gesehen dass sie es problem hätte
sie sehr häufig überzeugt dass sie sehr
gut zu ändern die bürger und das macht
der b-serie lösung finden die gar nicht
ganz einfach
auch walter f war mit seinen katzen
überfordert über 40 waren es einmal hier
könnten so seien hier so keine da sitzen
sie sonst gerne nun sich aber gründlich
versteckt da hilft auch alles ganzen
klöster nicht wieso sind denn hier die
haut zusätzlich das war anders am anfang
wenn ich ein besuch kriegte uns so dann
haben sie sich nicht stören lassen
aber seitdem die eben eingefangen worden
sind gewaltsam da sind sie traumatisiert
vier katzen sind ihm geblieben alle
anderen wurden beschlagnahmt
[Musik]
aufnahmen des veterinärdienstes bern
entstanden in der damaligen wohnung von
walter 11
[Musik]
vorstellbar daher hat über 40 kw 210 ps
wenn wir zu dem haus gegangen ist ein
stetiger vor deiner hat geschmack der 16
dass die hygienische zustand es ich sie
brauche noch vorhandene hotspot
richtiggehende traktierte sie mit uns
schädigen und der seite situation dort
wo man als walter f musste umziehen weil
seine alte wohnung unbewohnbar geworden
waren
der pensionierte psychologe sagt er habe
mit seinen katzen einen tiefen
psychologisches experiment machen wollen
ja ich wollte hauptsächlich die
hypothese bestätigen dass katzen
gruppentiere sind und keine einzelwesen
das hat sich eigentlich auch bestätigt
wenn ich dann gesehen habe wie sie alle
einträchtig auf dem sofa oder immer auf
den galerien und auf dem und auf den
schränken alle einträchtig 10
nebeneinander sitzen und und kein streit
und der frieden herrschte und meine
haupt wurzel ist eigentlich der heilige
franziskus den heiligen franz von assisi
verehrte er weil diese tiere mit respekt
behandelte oder sind experiment die
hatte ihre sprache weshalb stunde
wiesenstraße urin kot über als sie das
sagt sogar unter ernährt sich
hauptsächlich im alltag luft ja das ist
mir schon irgendwo aus dem ruder
gelaufen ich hätte da noch hilfe
eigentlich gebraucht und so habe ich das
alleine durchgezogen gebracht hat sich
nebel
das wollte ich eigentlich nicht zum
schutz verdienen na ja das wollte ich
eigentlich nicht her welche abgeben
können auch geld der 68 jährige walter f
ist alleinstehend und leben
zurückgezogen in der bergwelt
vater seine vier verbliebenen lieblinge
würden ihm helfen nicht zu vereinsamen
das ist auch hier genannt ja ja der
cluster hat immer überhaupt nicht klappt
trotzdem verbuchte verleiht wieso hat
jetzt endlich nur ja eben was ich
eigentlich gesagt haben die katzen kann
ich gar nicht leben geld dann haben sie
gesagt wie viel darf ich bei alten mit
häme des k4 holte sich karl bezeichnet
die hauptsache unterdorf halten diese
kastriert und mit über die haupt die
regelmäßige prüfung und griffige der
geiger verletzt dass dieser jetzt so gut
konzentrieren
im niedwald ischen stans werden heute 80
katzen kastriert die vorwiegend
verwilderten tiere wurden tags zuvor auf
bauernhöfen eingefangen
[Musik]
freiwillige helfer darunter tierärzte
sind im einsatz
da kann man jetzt bei uns rennt eine
rund 300.000 herrenlose katzen würde es
in der schweiz geben schätzt nicht ab
der rekord schön fixiert jeder hat kühl
halten nach unter jedem brauchte ich
gerade dieses über den märkten
audi hat horst die hatte und die
hausmacht patrick hat kein geld hat dann
immer mit der cdu setzte meist und
kastriert hat es ihn sehr fruchtbar
sie ernähren sich sehr schnell an zwei
bis drei pro jahr nur 28 herzlich im
schnitt über landet dann haben aber sein
einziges tier trotzdem gut acht
millionen hatte nach der kastration
bringt man die tiere an jenen ort zurück
wo man sie eingefangen hat
es sei denn ein tier wird von manuela
guter mann als pflege bücher aufgenommen
die frau hatte dass das bitte für schnee
immer gut wenn man im rücken weiß meine
notfälle ist
ich weiß nicht mit einer unterbringung
also nicht krank ist sie wird dem jungen
mann den namen romeo geben
ein paar tage später entdeckte romeo
seine neue welt lange wird der neue zug
nicht bei ihr bleiben
das heißt wir können ziemlich schlau die
zur suche führen ohne chemie nur ein
harmloser zwist zwei ihrer vierbeiner
wirklich grund zur sorge gibt er jedoch
sunrise sie wurde von guter mann
ebenfalls zur pflege aufgenommen
sie hat vermutlich eben zu wenig gut wie
sich über und ganz wie es nass den
schweizer seite schließt und dass man
jetzt genau zum sie was los ist ja gott
habe zwar hoch gute margrit höfer guter
mann
sie haben mir geschrieben sie möchte mit
besonderer als rede mit ihrer hat ja
ganz genau
dann ging ich trainiere ich mache mich
mal auf der marburger was sie vorher
meint und malt nicht gerade im kino ja
bitte tierkommunikatorin jacqueline auch
stellt sich für einen stundensatz von
160 franken auf katzen 1 1 bildreiche
ihr aus um zu spüren wie es geht
aber sie rettet das ist schon mal gut
also was sie gerade übernommen ist
schmerzen hat wie gott dann hast du
irgendwie schmerzen sagt die neu für
mich einfach wahnsinnig mühe trainierten
du bist du oder oder korrigierten
bisschen mache das sehr einfache pc
besser aus aber sich ganz klar wie die
mache ich leute die mein tag ich bin
nicht gesund ich bin immer der sonne ist
ludwig höheres hoch aber sie mache mir
kein liegende nie druck sie die hohen
raten wählen
aber sie ist sehr mir sehr sie mag
einfach nicht aus ihrem auto vierte frau
betrogen
zum trotz dünner und dass man genau
abklären sie sich doch bitte mal hast du
sie noch nie noch am selben abend hat
sie mit ihrem schützling einen termin
bei tierarzt kaspar una erstellen wir
zumindest schon mal blut
das so hätte so herrsche bluttat wurde
ein benutzter wieder probieren
ich bin schon blöd dass kunden hinter
der gefühle dann möglich wenn man die
überreste wenn das schlimme krankheit
grundlegend
dann macht's kreisen
manuela guter man muss mit allem rechnen
sunrise habe eine überlebenschance von
30 prozent sagte tierarzt beim abschied
[Musik]
das war carter lacie wenige wochen bevor
er an organversagen starb das tier
gehörte julie nancy paul dales um den
verlust zu verarbeiten stellt sie nun
aus laces pfotenabdruck silberschmuck er
vor lauter trauer war die 55-jährige
längere zeit nicht in der lage ein
interview zu geben
das ist ohne von ihrem verstorbenen sie
wohl leider habe versuche mir sogar
voraus dass die jetzt der verlust der
voller menschen wie ich sie ja absolut
ich gott da mache ich keinen unterschied
das ist vielleicht für analytik
verständlich haben für mich ist das so
dass ich mir nicht hindert das ist wie
familie und dritte jahr das ist eine
lange zeit das ist anderthalb dekaden
und ja also für mich ist das sehr sehr
schlimm wenn das ich würde das nicht
können einfach durch ziehen
jedes mal wenn ich das mache ist das für
mich jedes mal wie schlimm
abschied nehmen von katzen musste auch
schon familie weber und jedes mal ging
auch hier der verlust sehr nahe der
stadt am ende ja nur fotos als
erinnerungen an die vierbeiner zu haben
reicht sandra weber nicht aus wo sie vor
hinein ist also sich mittlerweile ja
präpariert oder ausgestopfte warum hat
sie das mal will ich sie eine ganze
menge ich werde noch ist reichlich einen
marcel hacker also minimal schon gewarnt
wurde von meinen kollegen
das muss krieg passiert aber so wie wenn
wir jetzt nicht da ich ein mensch ich
habe bis 1 gültig wenn in moskau
er hat mir zum glück möglichkeit das
mache ich schon in mir ist schlafzimmer
dass ich nicht wirklich und minute tiere
hat man verstanden andere bezogen andere
möglichkeiten
daher ist eher mickrig und ja da immer
mehr geschlafen ich denke das ist besser
plötzlich mit mir im bett und eine
schöne leich und ich auch nicht ich fast
ja mach auch auf andere und das gab das
unausweichliche mühe macht nämlich sind
ja alles bestehende management sowie
möglichkeiten dem einfluss und darum
gibt mir das dach lee getrost bei
manuela guter mann daheim hat sich ein
kleines wunder ergeben
entgegen aller prognosen wurde die
schwer kranke sunrise wieder gesund und
jetzt hat die katzen pflegerin für ihr
pflege böse ein neues daheim gefunden
[Musik]
sunrise wird das neue familienmitglied
von ulla und heinz müller
[Musik]
das ist das schönste
ich weiß dass ich gar nicht
[Musik]
china präsentiert wurde wo honda jazz